what do you think about this
first of all the geopolitics of africa
and uh the geopolitical relationship of
africa with the rest of the world
and its current conflict
with the war in ukraine
what are your thoughts there well you've
seen that many countries when it was
time to vote
some of abstained you know which in a
way says something
i think for the africans today
especially as represented by the african
union because not all countries fall in
this along the same lines
i feel like again we're back to way back
for the longest time the west tries to
tell us what to do
they decide for us
and here
they are
there's trouble
meaning
there's definitely
a rift
major one
between most of the western world as
represented by you know europe and
america primarily now australian and all
that
um
and then then they're saying
you know
um i think this is more or less an
attempt to
to stand
on their own as well it's like you're
not don't tell us what to do as usual um
you always work us in with when it makes
sense for you to try to rope us in and
then we're left hanging on our own so
there's a this goes back to the
sentiment you were talking about earlier
it's been
challenging
for me
to watch this because remember
i have one foot also you know like
because there is what i get to see and
hear
from being in the western world
but there is also what i get to see and
hear
from when i'm in the back home
so i wear all hats
and
i think this is a situation where the
african um union
and african nations in general are
saying
we don't
it's this case we're almost like you
guys are fighting
you guys are fighting
maybe for once we have to watch it for
ourselves
yeah there's a sense in which
um
this is the embodiment sort of
you know abstaining from a vote on the
war in ukraine
is a political embodiment of uh
resistance to the influence of the west
right it's not about the war between
whatever you guys are fighting yes it's
saying
uh we're not going to
let this particular empire that seems to
be at the top right now which is the
united states empire in europe
to dominate our political uh discourse
our geopolitical considerations it's
almost like no we're not touching this
yeah especially when given usually so
when they need us again
for influence which means more power oh
you guys vote the same way we do
and when the it's all over and they go
back to
they go back to uh spreading um you know
they go back to um how do you say that
they go back to um
uh exchanging
and sharing between themselves the
goodies of uh you know their halloween
collection
we no longer we're not there when the
goodies are being shared
so i think it's it's definitely one of
those situations
but for me
it still is hard
because i watch everything that's going
on and um
i
it's going to be complicated for
ramifications of all of us
i would like to to see our african
leaders also what they're doing is is
clear but this is a place where i almost
i'm also tempted to say
yes and
um
yes to
the reasons you're advancing right now
you know of we don't want to be always
citing because we're tired we're tired
of always being dragged around and taken
for granted and you wrote our way you
know um come on guys uh when when you
need us we're we're great and everything
is good and then when it's time to go
and um share the goodies we don't exist
anymore and you actually go for
policies that go against us but in this
situation though
i would like to still see us do the
right thing in my case i was not very
happy to see
us going
and more or less begging for
you know
um what do you call it um cereals
you know oh please let the cereals um
make it so at least we get them and we
don't starve
i can understand why a president
would say something like that or try to
negotiate something like that
but when it comes to an african
president
having to do that
with a
non-african president
i'm sorry but for me it's too close to
begging
listen it's hard to be a leader it's
such a difficult dance because in some
sense
sort of
the
the flip side of that is
you're creating a market a geopolitical
market of saying
we're willing
to sit down at the table with america
with european leaders
with uh russian leaders with china
and we're going to let you guys convince
us
who
we should collaborate with
and that's what sort of great
um
nations and groups of nations do do now
there's a cynical of course a dark
perspective of that because
what's in in that game played by leaders
the people that hurt people ukraine hurt
people of africa can hurt people of
russia people of russia can hurt
people of china people united states but
it is the way of the world and to to
earn ris you have to
you have to earn respect and sometimes
earning respect leads to the suffering
of many well but except in this case
yes to all of that and
the reason why i'm actually upset
with with
going and being like oh can you let at
least the boats
that are supposed to come to africa full
of cereals come over the wheat and all
that
it's just like look africa has the
highest land that you can do agriculture
on yes you know
we have a larger surface such surface in
the world
why is this not a time for us to try to
wean ourselves off of cereals that we
don't necessarily have on the ground
but no
let us go and plead
don't beg create instead great instead
exactly this should have been you know
just like how the rest of the world when
uh kobet happened and china had to close
off for different reasons and since then
has not you know completely reopened and
people are starting to realize wow we've
got um we've got too much we're too
dependent on china for a lot of what we
need so we're gonna have to bring back
some production to the us the europeans
are doing the same all of that this
should have been enough a time for
african leaders to be like we we need to
be serious now uh about um you know food
security and maybe the stuff that
maybe don't grow under our climates
necessarily can we work on coming up
with different things now i understand
it can take time but um if i knew that
that was happening at the same time that
was saying oh well let the cereals come
in maybe i would be a little bit easier
with it but right now i'm just like is
it gonna be the same business as usual
and in this case i i'm just like are we
gonna go are we gonna keep going from
one massa to another masa
i mean really
you